[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le jeudi 9 décembre voici
les titres
cette semaine les rencontres de
l'inclusion se tenait à elancourt
l'occasion de faire le point sur les
entreprises s'engagent le dispositif a
atteint les 130 signataires dans le
département l'objectif fédérer valoriser
mobiliser les entreprises en faveur de
l'inclusion et de l'insertion
professionnelle s'est animée par face
yvelines c'est un projet d'envergure à
villepreux le quartier de la pointe à
l'enjeu va connaître une seconde
jeunesse une réhabilitation est prévue
d'ici à 2025 au programme logements
existants renouveler nouvelle
construction qui devrait débuter dans un
an et puis ce spectacle démarre ce soir
falaise s'installe pendant trois jours
au théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
danse clown chant lyrique guitares rock
ce rendez vous est proposée par la
compagnie baro d'evel et on en parle
tout à l'heure dans ce journal mais
avant de développer ces titres le plan
blanc est réactivé dans les hôpitaux
d'île de france face à la recrudescence
des cas de colis 19 et une tension
hospitalière qui s'est accentué l'
agence régionale de santé a pris cette
décision aujourd'hui le plan blanc
permet en pratique aux établissements
d'augmenter les capacités de lits pour
les patients en soins critiques
réorganiser les plannings pour assurer
une continuité des soins voire même de
permettre des déprogrammations dans les
yvelines le taux d'incidence est proche
des 450 en moyenne 15 nouvelles
hospitalisations quotidiennes sont
recensés dans le département dont trois
en réanimation
[Musique]
et je vous en parlais en titre hier
mercredi se déroulait la première
édition des rencontres de l'inclusion à
elancourt le principe mobiliser les
entreprises du territoire en faveur de
l'insertion professionnelle le
dispositif menée par face la fondation
agir contre l'exclusion a déjà réuni 130
entreprises signataires mathilde de
francs quand
fédérer valoriser et mobiliser les
entreprises yvelinoise en faveur de
l'inclusion voici l'objectif de la
fondation agir contre l'exclusion face
en partenariat avec la préfecture des
yvelines
ce nouveau dispositif permet aux
personnes éloignées de l'emploi de
retrouver du travail pour cela fasse
yvelines à deux plans d'action l'école
et l'emploi l'action emploi c'est ça
veut dire faire en sorte que les gens
qui n'ont pas de boulot donc les on peut
appeler ça les chômeurs de longue durée
trop un boulot et de l'autre côté on
travaille avec les jeunes
de façon que les jeunes des écoles
généralement les collèges mais aussi des
lycées est un projet professionnel cette
fondation permet de faire le lien entre
les entreprises et les personnes en
demande d'emploi c'est très important
parce que souvent on a des entreprises
qui me disent moi je veux m'engager je
veux recruter un alternant je veux mais
je ne sais pas comment faire je ne sais
pas où elle est donc la grâce à la
fondation agir contre l'exclusion
on a bâti tout les outils qui sont
nécessaires pour qu'une entreprise qui
souhaite par exemple recruté un alternat
par exemple recruté un jeune en stage de
3e le dispositif a permis la signature
de 130 entreprises yvelinoise ces
dernières se sont engagées sur 14 thèmes
comme par exemple recruter un apprenti
en l'occurrence la fondation mallet
recherche fin était par contre en tout
cas l'idée de prendre une alternance en
ressources humaines et
j'ai eu un entretien comme comme une
entretien d'embauché lambda et et ça a
marché c'est important surtout donner la
chance à tout le monde parce que nous on
n'a pas recruté cécile parce qu'elle
était en situation de handicap on a
recruté parce que elle avait un
potentiel en 2019 les actions de la
fondation façon bénéficie à plus de 358
personnes
ils auront ses méninges et m'a rejoint
en plateau bonsoir vous êtes chef de
projet à face yvelines la fondation agir
contre l'exclusion qui existe depuis
1999 dans le département des yvelines
s'est d'ailleurs on le précise le
premier club face à s'être implanté en
île de france avec trois domaines
d'activités qu'elles sont ils ces
domaines alors nos trois axes
d'intervention sont l'éducation l'idée
de réconcilier le monde de l'entreprise
avec l'univers éducatif
le deuxième axe et l'emploi puisque nous
accompagnons des demandeurs d'emploi
vers le retour et l'accès au travail et
enfin le troisième axe et l'entreprise
puisque toutes les actions que nous
menons nous sommes un club d'entreprises
et nous le faisons toujours en
partenariat avec des entreprises mais
dans votre crédo c'est justement d'avoir
des entreprises locales engagées pour
l'insertion professionnelle ça c'est un
credo que vous portez depuis plus de 20
ans dans les yvelines de sa wii et tout
particulièrement depuis deux ans la
préfecture nous a confié la mission
d'animer un dispositif gouvernemental
qui s'appelle les entreprises s'engagent
et qui vise comme le disait votre
reportage à mobiliser les entreprises en
faveur de l'inclusion et de l'insertion
professionnelle des publics les plus
éloignés et des dispositifs pour
l'inclusion pour l'insertion
professionnelle il en existe d'autres
qu'est ce qui fait l'originalité
justement de ce dispositif qu'est ce qui
change qu'est ce qu'il apporte de
nouveaux vraiment ce qui est important
dans ce dispositif c'est que les
entreprises de manière très concrète et
très pratique donne leur chance à tous
les publics éloignés de l'emploi en les
intégrant en leur permettant de
s'immerger dans le monde du travail soit
en réalisant des enquêtes métier soit en
faisant des périodes d'immersion en
réalisant des stages en accueillant des
jeunes en alternance donc vraiment
mettre un pied à l'étrier et ouvrir les
portes de l'entreprise c'est ça le plus
important et donc ce dispositif avait
franchi les 100 signataires en novembre
désormais on à 130 signataires c'est un
chiffre qui progresse et ça montre le
réel intérêt des entreprises justement
pour l'insertion professionnelle tout à
fait c'est vraiment pour les entreprises
valoriser leur engagement social et
sociétal par des actions qui sont très
très concrètes donc ça leur permet en
tous les cas d'être de donner de la
visibilité à cet engagement et ce
dispositif quelle que soit la taille de
l'entreprise et quel que soit le secteur
d'activité le dénominateur commun qui
nous réunit tous ces sept cet engagement
en faveur de l'insertion professionnelle
donc toutes les entreprises du
département peuvent nous rejoindre c'est
un dispositif qui est gratuit et qui est
extrêmement simple pour pouvoir
s'inscrire puisque nous avons un site
internet et qu en 2 clics
l'entreprise va décider d'au moins une
des 14 mesures qui est identifié et dès
lors qu'elles s'engagent sur au moins
une de ces mesures elle peut nous
rejoindre et faire partir de cette
grande communauté est vraiment la
finalité c'est c'est ce qui est le plus
important c'est ce petit coup de pouce
que nous pouvons donner aux jeunes mais
également aux moins jeunes puisque les
publics sont les résidents des quartiers
prions et de ville les personnes en
situation de handicap les réfugiés bref
tous ceux qui aujourd'hui n'ont pas les
codes de l'entreprise et non pas le
réseau et on entendait dans le reportage
des difficultés c'est celle de faire le
lien justement entre ces entreprises et
les demandeurs d'emploi pourquoi c'est
difficile de les faire se rencontrer ces
deux acteurs est
difficile de répondre à votre question
mais toujours est il que en tous les cas
il ya beaucoup d'acteurs
l'insertion sur le territoire qui est un
écosystème qui est extrêmement dynamique
et que finalement en étant animateurs de
ce dispositif on permet vraiment d'être
un connecteur entre les besoins des
entreprises et puis les réponses que les
différents acteurs du territoire peuvent
peuvent offrir et on est vraiment cette
connexion vous parliez des 14 mesures
sans rentrer dans le détail que distel
ces mesures difficiles pas le peut-être
alors en
faveur des jeunes je vous le disais il
ya le lait l'alternance il ya aussi le
fait de pouvoir faire découvrir le monde
de l'entreprise aux plus jeunes donc ça
passe par l'accueil des stages de
troisième la découverte des métiers
l'alternance on en parlait tout à
l'heure il ya aussi beaucoup de
d'immersion qui sont possibles dans les
entreprises il ya l'emploi des personnes
en situation de handicap il ya les
emplois francs pour les résidents des
quartiers prioritaires il yal embauche
des réfugiés par exemple il ya les
achats responsables également qu'ils
sont extrêmement importants il ya tout
tout la sphère des structures de
l'insertion par l'activité économique
les esat les entreprises adaptées et
enfin je terminerais peut-être par le
parrainage donc des actions de mentorat
que les entreprises et les salariés
d'entreprises peuvent mener auprès de
demandeurs d'emploi non justement en
matière de mentorat il ya un dispositif
dont on parle souvent sur tv 78 qui
s'appelle la job academy vous mené en
partenariat avec des entreprises pour la
troisième année de suite oui
construction dont le siège est à
guyancourt participent à l'initiative
le dispositif de la job academy permet à
des demandeurs d'emploi d'être
accompagné par des collaborateurs d'une
entreprise dans la famille la finalité
est de favoriser l'insertion
professionnelle regarder cette rencontre
signée de justin brasier nicolas landry
qui sont allés à la rencontre du binôme
and hématies de regarder c'est le
premier rendez vous d'une longue série
mathilde est actuellement en recherche
d'emploi anna est ingénieur chez
bouygues construction pendant quatre
mois mathilde et anne à vous constituer
un binôme formé en marketing dans une
école de commerce mathilde souhaite
trouver un poste dans le merchandising
du prêt-à-porter et se peut que je ne
trouve pas directement un emploi après
les quatre mois parce que c'est un un
partenariat qui dure pendant quatre mois
mais dans tous les cas ça me donnera des
pistes pour pour la suite et je sais que
je vais ressortir avec beaucoup plus de
plus que je me suis arrivé elle va
pouvoir partager son expérience et ça va
du coup me donner un peu de boost dans
ma recherche d'emploi ma reine de
mathilde anna l'accompagnera dans sa
démarche soutien moral conseiller sur la
recherche d'emploi partage d'expériences
l'ingénieur de bois de construction
s'engage auprès de sa fille à travers
des rendez vous toutes les deux semaines
pour moi c'est pas donner une solution
mais c'est plutôt
structurer un peu plus un projet
permette d'avoir régulièrement des étés
rendez vous
serra et puis d'avoir un suivi et un
suivi extérieur autre que un jugement
qu'on peut avoir dans la famille ou
amicales c'est vraiment un partage qui
peut être très intéressant et je prends
plutôt comme un challenge humain à côté
de mon travail qui est plus technique
pour le coup la job academy une habitude
pour bouygues construction le groupe
dont le siège est basé à guyancourt
participent à cette initiative pour la
troisième année consécutive
donc on est là dans une action de
mentorat finalement un salarié va
coacher un demandeur d'emploi pour le
ramener dans une dynamique d'emploi
pourquoi c'est intéressant justement de
recourir à ce genre d'initiative la
première des choses c'est que souvent
quand on est demandeur d'emploi souvent
que ce soit en accès direct ou bien en
dans le cadre de reconversion il ya tout
un travail de remise en confiance voilà
il ya pu y avoir un accident de vie et
donc ce qui est important c'est que le
parrain le salarié par un va redonner
confiance en demandeurs d'emploi en est
avec un discours très bienveillant avec
beaucoup d'écouté et souvent c'est
voile estime de soi a besoin d'être
d'être revalorisés et ça c'est la
première la première étape qui est
extrêmement importante après chaque
salarié finalement à lui même était en
situation de postuler d'être dans un
processus de recrutement et l'eau qu'il
va pouvoir avec toujours beaucoup de
bienveillance le questionner avoir un
peu un effet miroir sur wii il en est
son parcours quel est son projet quelles
sont ses compétences quelles sont les
compétences qui là qu'il va pouvoir
transférer sur un autre environnement
l'aider à rédiger son cv son sa lettre
de motivation et surtout ce qui va être
extrêmement important en fonction de
l'état d'avancement du filleul c'est à
un moment donné de pouvoir lui ouvrir
son réseau essaie de lui dire ben par
rapport à ton projet moi je connais une
personne ça serait intéressant que tu as
il a rencontré pour pouvoir échanger
avec elle d'assurer que les
représentations tu te fais de ce métier
là sont bien conformes à la réalité du
métier est comme ça de fil en aiguille
ouvrir le réseau et ainsi faciliter
vraiment le retour à l'emploi c'est
vraiment ce que vise c'est cette ce
dispositif on a vu c'était la troisième
édition pour bouygues construction ont
finalement il ya des entreprises fidèles
qui participent régulièrement à ces job
academy et combien d'entreprises en tout
il participe alors sur l'année 2021 par
exemple on a monté une dizaine de job
academy avec effectivement des
entreprises qui nous sont très fidèles
et qui tous les ans une fois qu'elles
ont découvert le système souhaite
renouveler puisque pour les salariés
c'est vraiment porteur de sens et pour
l'entreprise c'est important de pouvoir
valoriser cet engagement social et puis
de nouvelles entreprises tous les ans
nous rejoigne soit soit sous forme d'un
ter entreprises quand il n'y a pas
suffisamment pour les tpe notamment de
salariés pour s'engager donc on est en
capacité de réunir plusieurs entreprises
est formé une promotion avec avec toutes
les entreprises du territoire il
convient de fioul sur l'année 2021 par
exemple on a accompagné alors sur 2020
les chiffres consolidés sur 2020 sont de
400 salariés 20 demandeurs d'emploi
pardon accompagné par 400 salariés et on
a un taux de retour à l'emploi
ou en tous les cas de sorties positives
qui est de l'ordre de plus de 70% ça
veut dire que ça marche quand on fait ce
dispositif de la job academy derrière il
ya un retour vers l'emploi ça booste
réellement les projets des demandeurs
d'emploi donc soit de l'alternance soit
des projets de formation soit des
contrats en cdd ou en cdi c'est vraiment
ce qu'on appelle la sortie positive pour
2022 vous le disiez peut-être de
nouvelles entreprises pour cette job
academy on espère bien c'est notre
challenge et on retrouve toutes les
informations bien sûr si vous voulez
rejoindre ce club fassi bine sûr sur le
site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous laurence et medinger je rappelle
que vous êtes chef de projet à face
yvelines qui existe dans les yvelines je
le rappelle depuis l'année 1999
[Musique]
dans l'actualité un attentat à l'armé
blanche aurait été déjoué par la
direction générale de la sécurité
intérieure l'information a été révélée
par nos confrères du parisien deux
hommes ont été interpellés et début
décembre peck dans les yvelines et aussi
en seine et marne il aurait orchestré
une attaque prévue en ile-de-france à la
proche des fêtes de fin d'année un
projet d'inspiration djihadistes qui
prévoyait est de toucher au couteau des
passants au hasard dans des lieux
fréquentés une enquête a été ouverte par
le parquet national anti terroriste ce
projet au long cours à présent pour un
quartier vieillissant à villepreux
lapointe à l'enjeu va être réhabilité
dans son ensemble d'ici 2025 travaux
extérieurs et intérieurs nouveaux
logements sociaux et accession sociale à
la propriété
les travaux devraient débuter à la fin
de l'année 2022 le point avec mélanie
peau qui est nickel et demi d'euros la
voix de célia get on go
en 34 logements sociaux vieillissant
lapointe à langer à deux entrées de
ville les clayes-sous-bois et villepreux
datant des années 1970 le quartier va
connaître une réhabilitation complète on
a décidé de lancer avec le groupe
polylogis
le bailleur logirep un grand projet de
réhabilitation à la fois de l'extérieur
mais aussi de l'intérieur pour que les
pièces d'eau notamment et l'intérieur
des logements soit réhabilité et que les
habitants les locataires puissent avoir
des conditions de vie plus acceptable
initialement intégré dans le projet
central park porté par la municipalité
précédente le quartier de la pointe à
l'enjeu va se voir dotée de nouveaux
logements 20 logements locatifs sociaux
et 34 bourrée elle solidaire il ya un
objectif aussi de pouvoir valoriser
l'activité commerciale nous avons sept
commerces d'ailleurs je précise que
l'activité ne sera aucunement
interrompue pendant les travaux de
réhabilitation donc c'est de pouvoir
aussi accompagner nos acteurs
économiques et pérenniser leur
implantation sur ce quartier une surface
de 200 mètres carrés pourrait prendre la
place des actuels locaux associatifs les
travaux devraient débuter fin 2022 le
projet devrait se terminer à l'horizon
connaissez-vous la médecine intégrative
il s'agit d'un nouveau concept qui
consiste à réunir plusieurs approches
médicales l'objectif améliorer le
bien-être du patient et lui offrir un
suivi complet personnalisé opecst
justement un centre de médecine
intégrative anti âge a ouvert ses portes
voici un an le reportage de mathilde de
franco
fondée en septembre 2020 par le docteur
margulies ce nouveau centre souhaite
prévenir les effets du vieillissement
autant que possible il offre alors aux
patients un suivi selon quatre axes
nutritionnelle psychologique locomoteur
et morphologiques en fait c'est vraiment
un centre
pluridisciplinaire parce que on parlera
moins d'eux tous que j'ai pris mon
premier rendez vous il ya un an et demi
juste avant le co lead et au départ
c'était vraiment par observation pour un
rendez vous sur l'alimentation le
principe de la médecine intégrative
regrouper plusieurs experts en un même
lieu médecin coach sportif
micronutritionniste ou encore
hypnothérapeute ces derniers des
finissants suit un parcours de soins
avec le patient selon ses besoins le
docteur margulies mot confiné passion
une fois qu'il les a reçus sur une
première consultation
quand il détecte une problématique
émotionnel ça peut être une
problématique de dismorphophobie c'est à
dire que la la personne ne sera pas
telle qu'elle est c'est unionisme faux
faux mais la patiente où le patient sera
toujours insatisfait disposant de huit
salles de soins ce centre possède
plusieurs machines pour traiter
différents aspects du corps par exemple
la cryolipolyse médical permet de
refroidir de manière intense un amas
graisseux sur les cuisses les hanches le
ventre ou les bras le site est également
pourvue d'une machine de l'aide thérapie
c'est un programme pour renforcer la
circulation micro capillaire donc il
peut aider par exemple dans des
problèmes derrick rose ou de couperose
du visage donc c'est un prof un
programme qui va flasher qui va cas pour
but de renforcer la microcirculation
donc les petits capillaires les petits
vaisseaux qui permet de dilater dans
certaines pathologies problématique de
poux la médecine intégrative s'installe
peu à peu dans les yvelines un autre
centre a ouvert ses portes à montigny le
bretonneux
pour refermer ce journal un spectacle à
ne pas rater au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines falaise de la
compagnie baro d'evel une scénographie
apocalyptique avec un cheval et des
pigeons sur scène c'est à découvrir et
dès ce jeudi soir à 20h30 et ce jusqu'à
samedi ce qu'il faut savoir avec célia
gasson go
une falaise noir 8 chemin 14 pigeons et
un cheval voilà le décor surprenant de
falaise ce spectacle de la compagnie
baro d'evel se joue ce jeudi 9 décembre
à 20h30 au théâtre de saint quentin en
yvelines une métaphore d'un monde en
déclin on travaille beaucoup avec les
rythmes avec les voix avec le mouvement
il ya dans notre langage on a on vient
du cirque mais on est plutôt dans une
forme d'écriture contemporaine avec un
mélange de beaucoup de choses dans cette
performance qui mélange absurde et
humour les pigeons et le cheval font
partie intégrante de la troupe et du
spectacle on retrouve dans travaille
avec des animaux ou même avec des
enfants quelque chose qui nous
nour ali au moment présent et aussi
voilà cette espèce de connexion de la
justice qu'on cherche moi en tant
qu'interprète nom de rester juste tous
les soirs dès que tous les soirs on
rejoue la mémé carte pour refaire au
spectacle que ce soit un moment
extraordinaire cirque danse et théâtre
dans un paysage apocalyptique fallait ce
voeu d'être une oeuvre totale là sur
falaise il ya ce côté on rentre dans un
théâtre et on prend un peu le langage du
théâtre pour le détourner en faire autre
chose c'est pas un spectacle de théâtre
mais sale laisser penser peut-être
dénonce mais ça ne laisse pas ce que tu
es de cirque mais semblait quand même
donc c'est vrai que c'est là où je pense
ce
la singularité du travail devant relève
lé là dessus des autres représentations
sont prévues vendredi 10 et samedi 11
décembre toujours au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité demain vendredi place aux
7,8 week-end de l'actualité des idées de
sorties loisirs pour bien terminer la
semaine dans les yvelines belle soirée
avec tv 78
[Musique]